et maintenant j'accueille gastro sport
elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi de neuf
à rien
plus que mille quatre cent quatre-vingt
dix jours avant le retour de sarko à
l'elysée
elysée alors hollande est revenu faire
son stand-up voileux l'elysée comedy
club au micro un pupitre plafond mouluré
baumjohann alors encore fait une un
stand up sur l'autorité mois président
vous connaissez pas raul le truc est lui
qui fait un sketch sur l'autorité autant
de crédibilité que voir boutin
d'interpréter le lâcher de [ __ ]
par ya une semaine il parlait d'un choc
de simplification et là il décide de
créer une haute autorité de surveillance
olemps créateurs de haute autorité
depuis 2012 c'est le truc c'est que dell
c'est quoi ce terme de haute autorité ce
que je veux dire quand tu penses qu'il
existe une haute autorité c'est que tu
crois qu'il existe aussi une basse
autorités c'est surtout donc que t'y
connais rien en autorité
alors vous savez ce que c'est c'est un
mec qui bloquent l'entrée du ministère
de défense avec un vélib ouais c'est
hollande qui fait une tentative de
putsch
[Applaudissements]
il paraît que les grands leaders se
révèle dans la crise quand on voit le
mal qui se donne pour gérer une histoire
de reebok
alors inutile de dire qu'il n'a pas
mentionné héros pauvre jean marc ayrault
qui a apporté son soutien à borloo qui a
demandé une commission denquête sur
l'action du gouvernement durant la
sphère cahuzac du jamais vu c'est le
premier ministre qui est d'accord de
faire une commission pour être au
courant de ce qui se passe sous sa
responsabilité
alors opération transparence tout le
monde à poil mois le franchement
j'aurais préféré rien savoir
fillon qui a une bicoque dans la sarthe
duflot une twingo à 1500 euros belkacem
un livret à filippetti à l'appartement
de 70 m² on demande au ministre de
l'honnêteté pas de faire pitié
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est ça c'est cette idée grandiose
un dieu plus tu es pauvre plus c'est
bien vu coincer c'est un truc la france
avec le seul pays au monde où on est
fier de gagner le smic de rouler encore
au goût et de bouffe et offline
mais si on continue comme ça même les
roms voudront plus venir
il ce truc de transparence certains
savent aller [ __ ] mal ça va et déjà
des rumeurs sur fabius comme atteint
pareil qu il en train de vendre ses
tableaux pour acheter un stock de kangoo
c'est l'image quoi c'est l'image en tout
cas avec toutes ces histoires patrimoine
on sait au moins une chose moscovici ne
savait rien sur cahuzac il a aucun flair
ce type j'ai regardé son patrimoine le
tipi la duplex impôts belliard
la seule façon de faire une plus-value
la basse et s'il ya une montée du niveau
de la mer de 15 m
amour eva joly appelle à manifester avec
mélenchon le 5 mai prochain il fallait
bien qu'ils se rencontrent les de quoi
cela pouvait que connectés quoi c'est la
comédie romantique trop de crise de
l'année où quand robespierre rencontre
elena ceausescu c'est après hiroshima
mon amour le goulag dure trois ans les
dipôles potes
ou l'histoire du scandinave qui à la
ménopause découvre en même temps
l'orgasme et la langue française
[Musique]
parlante cinéma cinéma engagé véronique
jeunesse déclare dans le figaro pourquoi
j'arrête julie lescaut ah mais oui
pourquoi pour une fois qu'on avait une
série policière qui rivalisait avec les
meilleures productions ouzbek
tourisme alors je sais pas tout le monde
a vu cette photo de kim jong hun mahjong
de au backgammon 3 je sais plus très
bien
mais qu'il est fort faire croire au
monde entier qui va lancer une attaque
nucléaire alors qu'il fait du cheval en
camargue
c'est franchement c'est pas avec cette
photo qui fera trembler le monde farm
enfin on dirait attila avec des
problèmes de cholestérol c'est pas
moi je fais de la peine - kung fu panda
c'est beau mais parmi ces généraux là on
dirait un petit obèses kidnappé par une
maison de retraite du xiiie
arrondissement
métaphysique des liquides il paraît que
cahuzac était franc maçon ah ah oui
alors le nom de sa loge c'est locarno 28
à quand une ville suisse il est fort
pour brouiller les pistes lui quand
c'est un truc alors les gens évidemment
on se dira mais c'est quoi un
franc-maçon alors un franc-maçon comment
dire c'est trop snob pour être cateau
pas assez célèbre pour être juif
je réfléchis
l'endroit et de la manière
nécrologie
margaret thatcher est morte
thatcher on peut dire ce qu'on veut dire
là peut-être pas fait beaucoup pour les
mineures mais sans elle on n'aurait sans
doute jamais connu les clashs et les sex
pistols
alors jean luc mélenchon estime que
margaret thatcher va découvrir en enfer
ce qu'elle a fait aux mineurs vu le
poids politique du front de gauche c'est
surtout jean luc mélenchon qui
découvrira on en faire ce qu'il n'a pas
fait pour les mineurs
[Applaudissements]
moi je me méfie quoi un athée qui
croient à l'enfer mais ça c'est le
problème des laïques enragent écossais
sont tellement sûrs que dieu n'existe
pas qui s'estime légitime pour prendre
sa place passé un truc fun les journaux
évidemment se demande si il faudrait une
margaret thatcher en france ce serait
chouette hein
ah non mais elle à florange les de vous
proposer un reclassement elle se serait
arrangé pour vous filer la nationalité
indienne
[Rires]
ansari et casques
t'auras pas ton à greg jeu de mots alors
le grand rabbin de france gilles
bernheim déjà coupable de plagiat en
plus usurpé son agrès de philo ta manque
plus qu on découvre qu'ils organisaient
des soirées jean brouillette avec tariq
ramadan
[Applaudissements]
la rousse définition du mot mariage a
été modifié c'est plus l'union de deux
personnes de sexes opposés mais l'union
de deux personnes de sexe opposé ou de
même sexe bab l'art etc c'est faux faux
tout réécrire marriage act précédent le
divorce et dont le but est de faire une
jolie fête lorsque tout le monde se
supportent encore
sais c'est pas le seul terme a et
réécrire à d'autres comme filiation act
qui permet de retrouver le connard ou la
[ __ ] à qui on n'a rien demandé
adoption coup de pouce du destin qui
permet à certains gosses de tomber sur
des parents plus compétents que ce livre
est d'origine
après une nuance enfants adoptés
vietnamiens enfants très prisé par la
bourgeoisie du 16e arrondissement du
fait de la ressemblance physique qu'il
développe avec la mère adoptive une fois
qu'elle a passé ses premiers lifting
[Applaudissements]
alors peut-être une bonne nouvelle pour
terminer c'est pierre bergé vos des
préservatifs gratuits au collège comme
si les profs n'avait pas les moyens de
s'en acheter
alors à belle la vie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu